Trevor Bauer so here's a guy that wins a
Cy Young okay and I know you and him
have gone back and forth and so he wants
to Cy Young you know he calls it the
Mickey Mouse trophy whatever he calls
he's also another guy that's a good
troll he knows how to get under people's
skin and he was doing it regularly
and but this guy was a you know
qualified star pitcher you know he was a
great he won the Scion you don't win the
Cy Young luckily and then all of a
sudden the story comes out
and uh you know he can't play he's not
getting paid not play again you don't
think he's ever going to play again but
is that deserved though no absolutely
not no no he nothing happened so what do
you mean he's never gonna play you know
as well as I do especially when you're
talking about corporations and images
and and a majority of owners are very
liberal people they're not going to
touch him because
Sports has gotten to a very
uncomfortable place the the professional
sports has started to cater to fans who
don't buy tickets
if you think about the fans they're
catering to they're catering to the fans
who will go to their sponsors and
boycott their sponsors not the people
that show up at the Ballpark or the
stadium or the arena or the rink and
there's think about the blowback I mean
first of all
look at the DeSean Watson stuff and how
that's I mean Cleveland I always say you
know we if you're a if you're a
Cleveland Indians fan or you're a Mets
fan or you're a Rangers Fan you can't be
mad at Players right if you're bad for
30 years the roster turns over your
coaching staff changes the only constant
is ownership
and it's it's owners just consistently
suck at things and it's just the way it
is Daniel Snyder there's a reason the
Redskins are continually bad
you know there's a reason the Cowboys
with the Supreme roster haven't made
that final step when the owner starts
the medal
who's making that when the ownership
starts to meddle with the if you're
going to hire people to do things let
them do it you know you know that from
business right you hire you bring people
in you you bring in someone to run your
HR department and then you meddle in
every decision that's made that person
is not running your HR department so
you're saying he's done done he'll never
put you think he'll ever pitch again
well again what can he do though as a
player like you know we have a legal
system right we have a Justice and what
what can you do can you hire lawyers and
go what what can he do
and there's still nothing's gonna happen
and
I sometimes I feel like sometimes I get
asked questions you know the answer you
know the answer in this day and age with
with the way Society is going it's not
going to get better for him things
aren't going to improve suddenly people
are just going to suddenly start saying
well it's in the past I mean there's
there's some things that we don't have
second chances for in any capacity and
that has to be things with children you
know things with with women and abuse
and things we don't give second chances
to people like that and in many cases
but see he was this was not there was no
legal basis for them to do this other
than he offended Major League Baseball
yeah but district attorney sat on it for
nine months and then didn't file yeah
but but if you if you go to it when they
drop charges I mean correct they didn't
find enough evidence go to the Cowboys
remember the Cowboys when they always
had issues Leon every time stories would
come out well this person this and that
person this and grows this and you get
LT stories would come out none of that
is even close to what this is consensual
sex he had the girl comes back for a
second time around right and and all the
text messages to back up all of it all
of it and you still don't think he's
gonna ever play do you
I would think which team would risk yet
to sign him which team would be somebody
that would happen and let's just add to
the fact that he's clearly kind of a
dick I mean if you look at the way his
teammates have talked about him and the
things that he'd done I mean he and I
got into it over the fact that he cut
his finger on a drone during the
playoffs and caught any and his response
was well we won the game I was like well
it wasn't about winning the game that
wasn't the thing you taxed your Bullpen
because you were [ __ ] around with a
drone and it cost your team down the
road he's he's a little short-sighted to
see this unbelievably gifted talented
pitcher but I don't think there's any
team that would want the headache but
Kurt all it takes is one like what
happens to mind is like you know in the
80s and 90s in the NFL who was the team
that would sign all the players with
problems the Raiders Al Davis so if you
had a freaking problem you know if
you're the recent Antonio Brown we're
past that that's what I'm saying is
there a team in baseball that's like all
right we'll be the badass team who was
the running back for the the Ravens so
Ray Rice Ray Rice yeah I mean if you
look at some of the stuff but what he
did was astronomically worse I apologize
for using that as a comp that's not
really but if you look at what's
happening now it it's got
at the end of the day that's why people
say oh you played a game for a living no
no baseball is a 10 billion dollar your
business they'll never forget that
the only thing owners hate more than
than bad press is losing money and this
there's no what's the advantage
to bringing this guy in
he has to win 20 games 25 games with a
sub 2 er8 to be even remotely Break Even
because of the blowback you're going to
be dealing with even if you give them a
veterans minimum well the guy who used
to make 30 million here's the problem I
mean you gotta there's gonna be some
value there no the problem becomes when
you go to a New York every single start
of Trevor Bauer's season all 25 guys are
being asked what they think about Trevor
Bauer it's an enormous like headache it
is and your teammates have to deal with
it and you know I'm sure I've seen video
he's running around like throwing to
hitters I've never heard of and I think
that's my phone actually I apologize for
that oh I thought I turned it off those
are my chickens bucking but no one wants
to deal with it and I you know I really
don't blame them I I it's it's it's but
but just so you know at 30 years old his
country so here's how we got paid he
played photo Diamondbacks for four years
uh for two years he got 1.18 then he got
two years Indians 1.18 then he went to
one one nine then it went to 3.5 million
with the Indians then six five then 13
million Indians then 17-5 Reds then 31
Dodgers 35 Dodgers he's supposed to be
at 35 obviously he's not getting paid
this is going to cost this guy oh
hundreds a couple of hundred million
dollars and he's at the peak of his
career
peak of his earning potential peak of
the earnings potential ah man this is
this is a very very strange to me me oh
you see the way baseball's played it so
they they let the they let one section
of it play out so that goes from July to
the end of the next season so there's a
year and a half of career until just now
we hand down the two years so now he's
got two years so now you're out to the
end of the 24 season so effectively
that's three and a half Seasons at 30 to
40 million and so baseball is drawing a
line at three and a half years and
they're just saying okay I dare you just
leaving it in the hands of the owners
right it's like three and a half years
from now three and a half years from the
The Fury that went with it and by the
way I got two daughters and no one wants
to read about this kind of stuff no none
of us do I said but
my legal brain says you know it was
consensual between two adults and it's
really unfortunate that that it went
this way however baseball's setting it
up yeah three and a half years which
owner would like to cross the line he
clearly doesn't have a lot of common
sense who who which which owners in
baseball are conservative like you know
how you know Jerry Jones is conservative
like you know where he stands you know
where Robert Kraft stands you know how
certain people stand you don't know who
they are there are so there I know some
but but they don't make it public
they're quiet about it well again it's
not a it's a it's a loss leader it's
going to bring in it's not going to help
your bottom line to be openly
conservative now
why would it not help your bottom line
to be openly conservative because
because of the activism it's the same
argument we use politically we talk
about fans though that's going to show
up but it's not about the fans it's
about it's about the people that aren't
showing up the people that are going to
go and boycott your sponsors right that
you're talking about and now look at the
contracts look at the payrolls TV gen
the revenue is all coming through the
through through video how much of the
decision of him not coming back is a
Manfred how much of the decision is the
owners
I would say probably 95 5. 95 is
manifold yeah yeah I think that's how it
yeah oh like the commissioner doesn't
want him in the league he's done bad PR
bad publicity there's no upside can he
can he go to Japan today and get paid a
real kind of money no no no no no
nothing to nothing pays the way we no
and I don't know I don't know about that
I don't know if he could go to I don't
know how Japan would I don't know how
they'd handle that because you don't
read about this with Japanese players
you don't read about this in the Korean
League or any of that other stuff where
Tom select played him played in a movie
years ago remember that Mr Baseball
I loved it over there I I went over
there on a tour with the team we played
I that was Heaven that was that's what I
hear that's what I hear from a lot of
different people anyways listen for for
uh uh for a guy Who's Got Talent who
didn't break the law and they're taking
this position if if manfred's position
was different would the owners also take
a different position on it
they might take a bit different because
I don't I'm I I can't see a team
stepping up to do it not in this
environment I know a lot of athletes
that did a lot of things 10 times worse
were not good players who still played
and they were forgiven two three years
later yep well I mean we we've the world
has forgiven Pete Rose even if baseball
hasn't I mean Pete Rose bet on his team
to win and lose as a player to manager
it's a it's a rough thing to you you
know to replace a 35 40 million dollar
your job there's not a lot of places you
can make 35 to 40 million yeah that's
your skills yeah so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
foreign
[Music]